right now if you google the word idiot
under images a picture of Donald Trump
comes up I just did that how would that
happen how does search work so that that
would occur we provide search tree for
anytime you type in a keyword we as
Google we have crawled we've gone out
and crawled and stored billion copies of
billions of web pages in our index and
we take the keyword and match it against
web pages and rank them based on over
200 signals things like relevance
freshness popularity how other people
are using it and based on that you know
at any given time we try to rank and
find the best results for that query and
then we evaluate them at external
Raiders to make sure that and they
evaluate it to objective guidelines and
and that's how we make sure the process
is well it's not some little man sitting
behind the curtain figuring out what
we're going to show the user it's
basically a compilation of what users
are generating and trying to sort
through that information last year we
sold over 3 trillion searches and just
just as a fact every single day 15
percent of the searches Google sees we
have never seen them before so so this
is working at scale and you know we
don't you know manually intervene on any
particular search result
you